hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal einen
gemüseauflauf wirklich ist was ganz klassisches
was schnell geht was man bis in den ofen schiebt
und wofür man einfach nicht zehn jahre überlegen
muss was koche ich heute heute komplett ohne
fleisch und ich fange jetzt auch direkt an die
ganzen mengenangabe schreibe ich euch wie immer
unten in die infobox und ich nehme heute die
drei klassiker für mich ist es halt wirklich
immer blumenkohl brokkoli und kartoffeln ihr
könntet auch möhren dazu geben oder ich habe
mir einfach was für euch in seinen klassischen
gemüseauflauf rein muss ich habe es gerne jetzt
in die kommentare weil wenn ich hier so lese dann
fange ich schon andere inspiration zu sammeln
fürs nächste video wichtig ist dass wir das
alles schön fein säubern also wirklich unter
fließendem wasser waschen und jetzt blumenkohl
und brokkoli in feine röllchen schneiden und die
kartoffeln wenn ich gleich schälen und entweder
hobelt ihr sie fein oder ihr schneidet sie in ganz
feine scheiben denn heute wird nichts vorgekocht
das gemüse habe ich jetzt direkt in meiner
auflaufform gegeben ihr könnt eure auch schon
vom auch noch fett wenn ihr euch unsicher
seid oder wenn ihr denkt lebt noch immer
was dran bei mir geht das eigentlich immer
ganz gut klar ich nehme jetzt als basis sahne
und milch einfach damit nicht ganz so fertig
ist einfach zusammen in eine große schüssel
geben und dann hab ich immer so zwei optionen
die ich gerne mache entweder nehme ich jetzt
einfach nur auf die schnelle mein café de paris
gewürzes ist eine kräuter gewürzmischung als
auch schon knoblauch petersilie der täterin
einfach geil nehmen verrühren und dazugeben
falls ihr die nicht daheim habt habe ich für
euch eine andere alternative und zwar nehme
ich daher gemüsebrühe frischen knoblauch
paprikapulver edelsüß und salz und pfeffer
so ich hab jetzt die soße komplett
einmal darüber gegeben und ich möchte
es folgendermaßen ich nehme mir jetzt
alufolie und jetzt einmal verschließen
das hat den einfachen grund dass auch
wirklich alles gut und nachher werden
das natürlich überbacken was für ein auflauf
wenn jetzt nicht mehr packen wäre also ich gebe
dann gleich nach 45 minuten bei 200 grad
ober unterhitze den käse darüber entfernt
natürlich natürlich die folie und wird dann
noch mal so goldbraun backen das dauert dann
im anschluss nochmals 20 bis 25 minuten und
dann ist er auch schon fertig der auflauf
wir machen jetzt den testlauf von meinem gemüse
auf den gast kind bei mir immer ganz auf durch
auch sehr oft sogar sehr sehr um immer so
blumenkohl broccoli kartoffeln mein name
ist gesund sein schlagzeug herrsche große
gefahren oder hat vielleicht auch gut so
denkt sich eigentlich aber das
ganz genau ich hasse es wirklich hasse es wenn
also ich bin doch dank aber ich hasse es wenn ich
einen zu kleinen teller bekommen bei michaels
amerika bereits nach links aber dafür hast du
doch so ein tablett du weißt doch nicht ich mag
das nicht ja das hast du damit und sagt jetzt
hier nicht beschweren lokation auf höchsten
also handelt dann einen teller wollte immer
schon als du das ist ich das natürlich
doch also ohne witz man kriegt mich
immer in ihrem dunkel war es direkt durch
geflutscht das ist ja schön leicht das ist
ein klassischer klassischer ablauf und der
geht immer und immer und stoppt den eben
auch kinder finde ich gut lecker lecker
so ich würde mal sagen wir wünschen euch
viel spaß im nachnamen haben sie doch mal
was zu sagen mein teller geht damit zum
esstisch und gestern zu ende geht macht wohnt
ergeben du bist mal die hälfte denn wir sehen